in 2013 the world was introduced to a
groundbreaking piece of entertainment
naughty dogs the last of us gave us a
harrowing tale of ali and joe
a pair of survivors their fate brought
together in a post-apocalyptic world
brought about by a viral infection
the almost universal acclaim for the
first game would have sufficed
but it was the idea of developing an
even more amazing story that called to
noridor
it was undoubtedly a risk and much to
our delight the last of us part 2 can
easily lay claim to being the best game
of 2020.
[Music]
before we begin if you haven't already
show us some love by subscribing to our
youtube channel following us on facebook
or visiting our website so you can stay
updated on the latest geeky news and
tidbits
there is no running away from it this
sequel like the original will be
divisive but more importantly what you
will take away from the game is beyond
the impact it will have on you as a
player but also as a human being
the simple revenge trope has been pushed
to the forefront by the game's marketing
but that's just a small part of the
overarching teams that naughty dog is
exploring
although we will not go too much into
the story details due to spoilers
know that the last of us part 2 will
often have you ask yourself
how far would you go
no matter where you encounter the human
enemies
it is clear that the last of us part 2
intends to paint them as more than just
obstacles to be rid of
these are leaving characters that have
formed relationships share values and
have a common goal
the multifaceted nature of being a human
being has never truly been realized in a
game the way the last of us part 2 has
it makes for some truly wonderful drama
and storytelling
and evokes plenty of thought and
reflection on the part of the player
the craft and deafness that the team
displayed while putting together this
game is simply astounding
that is not to say that every single
aspect of the story is unique
far from it
it is the fact that it can take
well-thrown tropes and still manage to
hook you in that makes it an outstanding
piece of interactive fiction
at last the last of us part 2 is a tale
that cannot exist without adventure and
combat
one can be contented to just immerse
yourself in this gorgeously written
story
but the pure enjoyment of the gameplay
is yet another wonderful aspect of this
game
ellie has survived some impossible odds
to get to where she is
and there are more obstacles in a way
throughout the last of us part 2.
five years on from where we left her the
19 year old heroine has some new tricks
up her tattooed arm and snaps
ellie can crouch and move behind mo's
cover
and she can go prone as well hiding
underneath objects and in tall grass
in certain situations you can also
utilize water as a means of escaping
detection
killing silently is a key part of
catching your foes by surprise in
addition to a trusty switchblade ellie
has improved her crafting skills to
create tools like an improvised
suppressor for her pistol
a bow and arrow also offers another
option at range it is utterly satisfying
to navigate an area and silently picking
off your foes with none the wiser
this gameplay look of dangerous stealth
split-second decisions and resource
management makes for an additive and
addictive concoction
of course it is likely that you'll be
discovered at some point and that is
when you can truly go loud
motor cocktails explosive traps smoke
bombs and more are at their disposal to
disorientate disperse and ultimately
dispatch of this impediment
the limited number of resources
available drives home the fact that
survival is not guaranteed and you must
make your actions count the pistol and
revolver are handy in the pitch while
the shotgun is perfect for blasting
anyone who gets up close
the rifle returns giving ali a longer
range option to snipe or fire off a
damaging round
parts found around the world can also be
used to upgrade each of your weapons
bring not just functional improvements
but a visual change as well
listen mode returns allowing ellie to
have a limited view of the moving
creatures around her surroundings
it is definitely not a perfect solution
as you will still be restricted by your
environment
however it gives you the option of
planning a more strategic approach
combat mapping out how exactly you want
to go about taking down your enemies
the new skills upgrade system in the
last of us part 2 will be tailored to
how you want to approach the combat
situations
certain skills allow you to move faster
while holding a hostage while making
crafted items more effective
it is up to the player to decide where
to invest the finite resources you have
even with more skills the challenge each
faction brings to the table is very and
equally brutal
for the infected the runners are forced
to be reckoned with in numbers
the return of the blind but noise
sensitive clickers was couple more's
plans
get caught and in his instant death
stalkers are also back albeit with some
nasty upgrades
these creatures as seen in our preview
are equally sly as they are dangerous
utilizing the same stealth the ali can
these creatures rely on weight to ambush
you and listen mode is unable to detect
them as well
bloaters are also back with their
hulking frame and armored bodies
dangerous as ever
a new addition is the chambliss
creatures that love to charge at you
while using nauseous gas clouds as range
attacks
get too near and your skin will bubble
from the toxic fumes
there are certainly more horrors lying
in way prepare yourself
the wolves function more like soldiers
using conventional firearms and blunt
weapons the seraphites are more covert
in nature utilizing bows and arrows more
than firearms and some truly sharp tools
as well
both factions are also in possession of
guard dogs able to sniff you out via
your scent forcing you to be constantly
on the move
ellie's new dodge move is extremely
useful get the timing down and get
escaped to fight another moment or
establish stealth again by getting away
from the prowling enemies
fighting against these humans is a stuck
departure from battling the infected
there is more emotion at play
considering that these are human beings
the way they talk about their lives the
world at large and even when they
discover one of their own death it
provides additional gravity to your
actions and the unforgiving world of the
last of us part two
the limited open world design of the
larger bus part 2 also plays a big part
in how you experience the game
in dangerous situations the larger area
of play provides more options and
avenues in which you can leverage to
your advantage beat snaking through
cover and avoiding combat altogether or
eliminating petrols entirely
this newfound freedom is an awesome way
to enjoy a core aspect of the last of us
part 2's gameplay
in between intense set pieces and combat
scenarios the true beauty of naughty
dog's environmental storytelling truly
shines
the last of us part 2 allows the player
to make the most of their own curiosity
rune buildings can lead to hidden
secrets abandoned houses can tell a
heart-wrenching tale of abandonment and
despair
there are instances of hope love hate
and myriad other emotions that are
conveyed by delicate environments and
enlightening collectibles
much like ish in the last of us the
stories that you will discover in the
last of us part 2 expands upon this
world and gives you an inkling of how as
individuals we each react differently to
the circumstances at hand
like other monumental pieces of art that
drives discussion and debate the last of
us part 2 can certainly make a case for
being part of that conversation for its
portrayal of the human condition
or if you prefer the more whimsical side
of games
the game's extensive collection of comic
book heroes in the form of cards also
provides much entertainment in the chase
to obtain them
the environments also introduce some
like puzzle mechanics to spice things up
there are areas that require some clever
thinking to traverse
hidden secrets that require a short eye
to catch and plenty are locked saves
their hideaway valuable goodies
the latter remains a highlight
throughout the hours spent in the last
of us part 2 requiring you not to just
study your environment but piece things
together to find that elusive unlock
combination
on occasions you will be joined by
allies that provide more than just
combat cover
these characters more so than the anime
factions you will meet are better
developed as foils for the narrative in
the last of us part 2.
providing context to much of what you
see and what you do their individual
relationships to different parties also
shed more light on the motivations that
drives much of the story's development
the banter the concern the anger and
more are all part of being a human and
these are some of the best
representations of that in video game
form
unfortunately they too suffer from the
shoes of the first game
namely that they are invisible to the
enemies for as long as they want to be
of course the ai has been improved
vastly with allies doing their best to
maintain stealth
things are even better when you're able
to pull off double stealth kills or have
them come to your rescue in dire times
the performances of everyone in the last
of us part 2 are great contributors to
his billability the likes of ashley
johnson troy baker and laura bailey are
instantly recognizable to most gamers
but the performances of the others truly
help elevate the game to new heights
the nuances in the expressions body
language voice acting and motion capture
make everything in the last of us part 2
matter
emotional moments are heartfelt intense
sequences are almost painful to watch
and the relief and making out of a
mortifying situation can be felt through
your entire being
there is much to admire about the detail
to which dontydonk and the actors put
into their craft
the way lighting hits objects and the
characters the gorgeous animations the
world building this game is a looker for
as much as we are looking forward to the
next generation of consoles sony's
current console can still impress even
at this late stage for those facing
accessibility issues that exist in
reality naughty dog deserves a pen on
the back for including what is likely
the most inclusive set of accessibility
options in games ever
vision hearing and modal aspects are
covered with customizable options to
fine-tune the experience even more
alternate controls visual aids motion
sickness auto cues and more are
thoroughly addressed in class of us part
2. even the difficulty can be customized
so you can enjoy all the exploration
without worrying too much about combat
as an example
[Music]
if you want to play this game the death
team has made sure you will be able to
no matter what problems you might face
seven years on much of the gaming
industry has evolved with the last of us
part two naughty dog has set out to tell
a character-driven story that reflects
who we truly are flawed individuals that
sometimes make some difficult choices
by combining some truly stellar
character moments with strong narrative
hooks
improving upon a solid foundation of
combat and stealth and expanding the
freedom of the player the last of us
part 2 is a sequel we never knew we
needed
after being challenged lifted up
emotionally wrecked and ultimately
inspired the last of us part 2 delivers
one of the best narratives in games
backed up by solid gameplay foundations
and is simply the best game ever put out
by naughty dog
for more details on the last of us part
2 and other video game news check out
the links in the description below until
the next one stay geeky
[Music]